a replica of where the Nazi regime came
to an end the underground bunker where
Otto Hitler committed suicide on April
30th 1945 the war he had started still
raged on the streets above once the
Soviets occupied Berlin Hitler's bunker
faded from history and was later
destroyed now a new exhibition is
offering insights into the fearless last
days with a replica of the dictators
living quarters we're trying to
demystify Hitler debunk his legend after
70 years and present the facts what
remains is an insidious dictator who
shot himself in a basement once it
became clear that his enemies had beaten
him Hitler spent two whole months living
in the shelter behind his Chancellery in
Berlin along with his girlfriend a
four-pound as seen in the german movie
downfall the dictators entourage still
lived in surreal luxury meanwhile the
German capital was being reduced to
ruins troops and civilians followed
orders to keep fighting
many losing their lives in the process
the relocation of Hitler's actual bunker
is easy to miss visitors from around the
world still flocked to it some with no
clear idea of what happened here it's a
few a bunker right that's all I know
I found everything about this very very
interesting played a key role in
Berlin's history that's why I want to
see it the new exhibition called
documentation free of Ibuka opened in an
air-raid shelter still standing from
World War two visitors get a glimpse of
Hitler's final days but they also find
out how ordinary people survived in
overcrowded shelters at the end of the
war a key exhibit is this model of
Hitler's bunker its designers chose not
to use Nazi symbols to avoid creating a
pilgrimage site for right-wing
extremists
but additionally he jnana neo-nazis
don't want to see how Hitler shot
himself in his bunker or him me saying
neo-nazis are hideous
they wouldn't enjoy our tours at all but
a Nolan sir and his team did choose to
use the term Fuehrer bunker not to
capitalize on Hitler tourism they say
but to educate people about the horrors
of the Third Reich